except if you if you get chocolate and
wine that's fine well that's okay to do
a little bit of a repeat
in some ways don't
take it 100 repeats don't surprise with
like
cereal or cheetos or something random
that wouldn't necessarily go well over
well with our loved ones
i think it's going to be a michael it's
going to be romantic valentine's
i mean we've got a chance of showers on
sunday and a lot of people may be going
oh
seriously but that could be very
romantic you know that's right stay in
put on the fireplace romantic music i
like that
we've got gorgeous skies out there if
you haven't stepped outside
our cameras as good as they look never
do it justice
as good as it looks in person so that's
why i really urge you to take your cup
of coffee step outdoors
temperatures aren't bad at all i mean
you'll still need a robe or a jacket
we still have low 50s and some upper 40s
around the valley
so clouds are kind of keeping
temperatures a little bit milder this
morning 40s
in perhaps this morning in sandy valley
50s boulder city searchlight in laughlin
and up the road
normally where we'd see teens with clear
skies in ely
it's 33 calientes at 36. so temperatures
are noticeably different
we're going to keep these cloudy skies
through the day even into tonight
slightly cooler mid 60s today more
sunshine comes back tomorrow really
through the rest of the week
until the weekend and then we've got
near 70 degrees almost every day
so it's going to be very spring and mild
spring-like
breezy weekend and then that chance of
showers on valentine's day
so all of this moisture excuse me is
pretty much mid to high level cloud
cover
we are seeing some showers up in
northern nevada rain and snow but
if we get a few sprinkles in our
mountains today that'll be about it
we're not looking for rain showers
in the valley 65 degrees not much in the
way of wind
again we'll keep these clouds tonight
into early tomorrow so a mild start near
50 degrees for wednesday morning
more sun through wednesday thursday
friday and look at those temps low 70s
for a couple of days
breezy winds through the weekend with a
chance of showers late
saturday night in through sunday and
again we might even adjust this a little
bit as we get closer presidents day we
get
back to more sunshine into next week 58
on sunday
another reason to put that fireplace on